hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Shaun Hill
we're gonna review the trailer today for
a video that just released and
everyone's raving about it Marvel's
daredevil Netflix show and I brought
Sean on because I wanted to prove I'm
not racist hey B Sean is a marble
enthusiast so I figured what better
person to bring on than someone who
actually loves marble I mean I love
Marvel I even read the first Frank
Miller was daredevil no way yeah I don't
really remember it so it's not gonna
serve me much when I watch this but yeah
[Music]
bless me Father for I said it's been too
long since my last confession I've been
preoccupied flip with questions of
morality good and evil perhaps this
would be easier if you tell me what
you've done I'm not seeking forgiveness
[Music]
forgiveness
[Music]
[Music]
city a better place
[Music]
all episodes April 10 all my birthday
that's my birthday I love that birthday
my birthday present to you
is making sure you watch all those
episodes on her birthday she looks good
that looks really good at first I was
like this kind of looks like a CW show
arrow is a good show and I hear flash is
pretty good too I wasn't a bad thing but
then it started and really having its
own tone I love the whole monologue he's
doing the whole time yes as being a
confession and it just leads into what
I'm about to do the knee oh I was so bad
I hope it sort of plays out like that in
the prologue it better and better cuz
that's always been sleepy when they
don't do that right man in terms of like
how they make a story in the trailer I
like the whole ass would be having a
story with the mature like the climax
Emmy is when he's like nah nah father
I'm not no making a confession of what I
write did yeah that's the greatest twist
for me right there and my heart was
beating really fast as yours yeah my
heart was really beating pumping blood
if you really depict the guy's tone in
his monologue
you could tell he has a full
understanding of this character yeah
he's not trying to be mr. badass hero
like there's there's there is a sense of
like genuineness in his voice and
sincerity in his voice like you could
feel that there's a guilt about it you
know like that's why he's going to
confession you could feel this sort of
hidden shame but he feels compelled and
drawn to the darkness Dan that's abuse
you really look into this yeah I feel
like you might be looking into it too
much no no I feel like it can never be
enough looked into honestly I'm that guy
that's like um like every line has to
mean something to the person yeah you're
saying it and you ever hear like why why
did he say that I don't understand then
it's like that that was kind of awkward
act
you know like every second I'm blue till
my nose man whatever stories about to
tell I'm like like this skies feel stuff
yeah that that's that's soul I like the
way they they always show him beat up
where they show like no he's not he's
not perfect doesn't never gets hit like
a real superhero badass real realistic
kind of guy they're keeping him in a
human form the other Daredevils seemed
kind of unrealistic he's a lawyer right
yeah he's a lawyer in real life
yeah so he's a lawyer but he's like this
awesome blind guy who has his awesome
powers and you think about it you think
about it he becomes a lawyer after he
was already like kind of daredevil he
was a kid when the accident happened
with the radioactive stuff raining and
so to know that that's his profession
that he got into actor being able to
tell if people can lie all this cool
stuff like all those powers I don't know
who this actor is yeah but he's again he
seems like he's gonna pull off the role
very well like he wasn't doing some
Batman voice sound like a real teacher
cuz that's what everyone does when
they're men see he just sounded like a
normal guy and then like you could just
feel the emotion in his words of that
confession it's badass but it's really
felt it's more than just badass it's
like do you feel that rare feeling of
justice no like a lot of a lot of
characters are based around that but
rarely do you actually feel that why are
you mad yeah sorry that's the word it's
good word my brother for my brother from
another mother
they altered up my mind what that's in
like Spanish and just from that first
shot you get a daredevil where the
cameras like panning behind and you
don't even see the front of the costume
but you're like yeah it looks pretty
badass actually yes yeah I see where
this whole speech is going yeah that's
it looks sweet and like the way it's
captured it has that dark tone about it
it has that haunting tone about it like
yeah they're capturing Hell's Kitchen
you know yes and you know what you think
of Batman a little bit but at the same
time
zone Batman he's his own yeah Jesus holy
is yeah he's got different kind of
powers and stuff and then he has a
different kind of weapons but yeah he
like same attitude he's kind of like
blind Batman yes well I'm back that's
deep oh yeah the way they are they do
the blurring out I love that because
it's hard to like make powers look like
they're being used sometimes you know
yeah well this is trying to hack but
trying to capture news since we've seen
it through his point of view
right you know so it is a kind of a hard
thing to just really decide on what you
want it to look like so they did a good
job a hell of a job like just doing
something quick like that and you feel
like boom after that yeah quick like
that feel it how do you feel my
girlfriend's not present I I almost
missed them you didn't mean that
sexually ah that's why I was getting
confused I just I was really pure about
that moment how was it oh yeah well BAM
boom like yeah yeah exactly
those are sex noises boom boom BAM boom
you always say boom when the climax oh I
don't know who she's playing but the
girl she's the actress and Trueblood who
played Jessica and she is an awesome
actress at least in the first season she
wasn't I mean after that they didn't
really do much riding with her character
and I was kind of disappointing than
that but you know she still didn't good
with what the script had to offer her so
yeah she's a pretty good actress nothing
like a like a creepy old guy in an
elevator for no reason like that looks
like he's blind to like I don't know
what what that was about right just like
creepy effect of it yep maybe it's is an
equal blind villain oh yeah - blocking
guys I think there's a real blind
eliminate fight together
two blind men only one will see victory
there should be in an episode where
daredevil has the verse a deaf guy yeah
they have this one image where I think
they show kingpin just the the back of
him not to come across the wrong way
here yeah yeah but kingpin is in black
in the comics right no he is not he is
not black about he's the farthest thing
from but he was black in the daredevil
movie yes because that was colorblind
casting that I was like all right yeah
and I couldn't tell if that was a black
guy he looked actually white from the
distance that I remember oh you would
know better yes though two things that
are really white about kingpin
Wilson Fisk is his real name whitest
name I've ever heard of right Wilson
fish and then also he was in an art
gallery not to be stereotypical very
white thing to do so I feel like he was
white just from seeing him in an art
gallery what do you think
I think whatever your point of views are
is fair equal and I appreciate
everything in Ferguson that part I jump
it across the things like that oh yeah
when he's you know Ponemah to my look in
between the yeah oh my god to see you
jump between those things like that
almost like like spider-man parkour
hardcore like agility his agility is
amazing his strength is somewhat amazing
I'm like I didn't know he could do all
that yeah that was kind of like a
stretch but the same common respect
because I was freaking an awesome moment
yeah the way the action is really being
captured if it doesn't look like you
know much a CGI or bunch of visuals like
you can tell these are real actors doing
like stunts these are real actors
fighting like it doesn't look like
they're trying to sugarcoat it or put a
bunch of filters on it like to make it
look good like you can actually see the
action that's going on and you can see
the stunt work actually at play thank
you
and some stunt doubles don't work I feel
like there's one of those under gravy
things of all movies oh it totally is
people like bones certain people have
died from yeah man it's awful but I hope
for the sake of me being entertained
that they continue to do their jobs I
even like the logo I mean the uh
whatever yeah how it says daredevil
excite oh yeah it does have that comic
book Flair about it I think that was
from the original comic I want to say it
was from the original way they wrote it
I would like to say that but I don't
know the mass that he's wearing now I'm
like 90% sure I'm like I know it looks
very Frank Miller based that's how I
remember he he was doing that in one
comic book kind of like the spider-man
intro when he was looking for different
costumes you just put that on to like
frickin just to start his vigilante no
yeah yeah you know just like I knew I
want to start doing this before I have
it all like I don't know fashion
accessory unit with it you know anyway
guys thanks for telling about that video
is out if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects and
you could check out Sean Hill's channel
he is the spoken word artist and it is
badass beautiful brilliant poetry
it ain't some like [ __ ] [ __ ] no
any good he's just very genuine yeah
dude I'm great I'm great at spoken word
yeah go to facebook.com into the slicer
real reject shadow sir earn yourself a
shadow watch I'll shout someone else
heck yeah heck yeah oh no I mean I'll
watch
the art of the shoutout makes me feel
like a boy when I was a Cub Scout
I was once fat and like a stout but now
I wish to give this shoutout subscribers
for a higher desire for Liars aspire to
admire that I write that's why you
should get it by the way by the way
quick announcement um you don't have to
do this whenever you hear poetry you are
able to clap
also you can scratch your balls that too
that works but no one can really hear
that or feel what you're feeling when
it's in unison you can hear a loud
scratching ball sound what a thing I
could taste that like that was it that
was really well described in your your
part lady aced it I could like feel
everyone's scratching their balls right
yeah see I'm like yeah I feel it it's
good feeling like the hairiness this way
we're embracing our genitals and our
sexual side it's okay yeah yeah we all
got them you know except for those that
don't
yeah yeah that was a contradiction like
poetry sometimes but really if there are